من البحر الى البر انتقلنا الى هنا الى
القاعده الامريكيه في المنامه
لنتابع كيف سجلت وما رصدت هذه المسيرات
المنتشره في الخليج العربي وكيف يتم
التعامل مع هذه التسجيلات التي ترصدها
سندخل الى غرفه التحكم هنا لنرى العلاقه
بين التسجيلات وطريقه التعامل معها
تابعونا
59 قبل 14 شهرا انه مختصه بتكنولوجيا
المتطوره لتحسين الامن البحري في المنطقه
فريقنا لا يتعدى ال 25 عنصرا لكننا نتحرك
بسرعه كبيره راينا المسيرات بالامس حين
كانت في المياه انتقلنا اليوم الى غرفه
القياده لنرى سيناريو محتمل لما همم يحدث
حين تصور هذه المسايرات تهديد محتمل على
سبيل المثال هذه احدى المسيرات وهذا تهديد
محتمل وهذه وجهه هذا التحديث ترسل الاشاره
عبر الانترنت
لعدد اخر من المسيارات التي قد تكون اسرع
على الوصول
وتطويق هذا التهديد المحتمل هناك اشارتين
او هذه الزوارق السريعه ترسل هذا التهديد
هذه النقطه الزرقاء هنا هو النقطه الزرقاء
هنا
اقتراب اكثر من التهديد المحتمل
وتنقل هذه الصوره بشكل الاقرب لتظهر هنا
على سبيل المثال وكانها بارجه حربيه
فبالتالي يتم ارسال القوات البحريه
للاقتراب من هذا المكان بعد تحديد هذا
التهديد المحتمل هكذا تتم هذه العمليه من
هنا عبر الرابط بين المسيرات وبين الرجال
الذين موجودين في غرفه التحكم او على البر
للانطلاق لمواجهه هذه التهديدات في المياه
[موسيقى]
النرويجن الاول للامن البحري الاقليمي هو
ايران وتصرفاته المزعزع على الاستقرار
وراينا امثله على ذلك كمجمه سفن تجاريه في
المياه الدوليه او تهريب مواد متفجره من
ايران الى اليمن نراقب كل هذه التهديدات
بشكل جديه وافضل طريقه للتصدي لها هي عبر
تقويه شركائنا بالمنطقها وتطوير
التكنولوجيا العسكريه وهذا هدف الافق
الرقمي
من القاعده الامريكيه في البحرين بديع
يونس العربيه